- Well, it seemed inevitable,
but now Mike Lindell, the My Pillow guy,
has joined the ranks of people
like Sydney Powell and Rudy Giuliani
who are being sued for billions of dollars
related to alleged defamation damages
related to all the crazy
things that they were saying
about the elections.
I've done lots of videos on how crazy
all of these things were,
but it's no surprise that Dominion,
one of the makers of these
election-related machines,
has sued Mike Lindell
for huge amounts of damages
that they have allegedly suffered
to their business and reputation.
Pro tip for anyone that is thinking
about committing defamation
against other people or businesses,
maybe don't create a whole documentary
called "Absolute Proof,"
where you document
all of the crazy nonsensical things
that you want to say that
are allegedly defamatory,
but you know, #NotLegalAdvice,
but anyway, subscribe or
I'll see you in court,
especially if you're Mike Lindell.